[The American Cancer Society presents]
[The Traitor Within / In Technicolor]
[A John Sutherland Production]
[Direction...George Gordon, Story... Norm Wright,
Music... Paul Smith, Art Direction... Bernice Polifka,
Animation...Pete Burness, Irven Spence, Elmer Watson
[Narrator:] Every three minutes someone dies
of cancer. Day after day, week after week,
month after month, cancer kills close to 200,000
of our people each year.
Yet more than one-third of these deaths can
be prevented. Fear, ignorance, superstition
are responsible for these needless casualties.
[Woman 1:] My dear, what a terrible disgrace,
they say she died of cancer.
[Woman 2:] I'm just sure that she caught it
from that old Mrs. So-and-so. Cancer germs
were all over the place.
[Man 1:] Once you get cancer, that's all brother,
you're through, that's one thing that can't
be cured.
[Woman 3:] A friend of mine told me about
a new medicine for cancer, just wonderful,
you don't have to have an operation.
[Man 2:] Everybody knows it's inherited; none
of my folks had cancer, so I don't have to
worry.
[Narrator:] Don't be a sucker, everyone's
chances of developing cancer are just about
the same regardless of heredity. We all have
to be on guard.
No case of cancer has ever been cured by patent
medicine, salves, paste, ointments or other
quack treatment. Cancer is no more of a disgrace
than pneumonia or any other disease.
Cancer is not contagious. Many people are
being cured of cancer every day. Now, to study
cancer's effect on the human body, let's assume
that our organs are like group of interrelated
factories.
Raw materials are brought to the factories
by the blood stream which travels through
the arteries. Waste products are carried away
by the veins, lymph canals.
The cells of the body may be thought of as
workers in these factories. These cells work
smoothly along on their routine job of keeping
the body alive and healthy. Occasionally a
cell dies.
[ Music ]
When this happens, a healthy cell merely divides
itself to fill the gap.
[ Music ]
When the gaps are filled by new cells the
division stops, and the cells go on with their
work. This is normal cell behavior and most
people live out their lives in this untroubled
fashion.
Once in a while, something goes wrong with
the normal cell and cancer originates.
A healthy, normal cell turns into a malignant cancer
cell.
[ Music ]
It steals food from the normal cell.
Dividing and multiplying relentlessly, cancer
cells crowd out the active worker.
[ Music ] [Large black cancer cells are shown killing healthy cells and dividing into additional malignant cells.]
Since cancer starts with one cell, it can be
cured if it is treated while it is still in
its original place, by removal through simple
surgery.
[ Music ]
By radiation from x-ray tubes.
[ Music ] [Black, malignant cells are shown being zapped by bolts of radiation.]
By rays emanating from radium.
[ Music ]
When every single cancer cell is removed by
surgery or destroyed by x-ray or radium, the
patient is cured, if cancer is not destroyed
when it is localized here's what happens.
This small cancer growth in the breast is neglected.
Now we're in trouble. The cancer cells have
escaped from their original location and are
getting into the lymph canal, although in
some cases cancer cells travel through the
bloodstream as well.
The malignant horde is on its way to invade
other parts of the body. The invading horde
reaches the lymph nodes under the armpit.
This is the last chance because when the cancer
cells escape from this lymph node, they move
from the armpit to the point at the base of
the neck where the lymph pours into the bloodstream.
Now they are pumped by heart action to the
lungs where many new cancers develop. The
blood then carries some of the cancer cells
from the lungs back to the heart which pumps
them out through the arteries to all parts
of the body.
When the neglected cancer has spread throughout
the body, there is no hope for cure.
[ Music ]
Fortunately many cancers can be cured if recognized
and treated in time. So look out for these
danger signals.
Any sore that does not heal, particularly
about the tongue, mouth or lips.
A painless lump or thickening, especially in
the breasts, lips or tongue, irregular bleeding
or discharge from any natural body opening,
progressive change in the color or size of
a wart, mole or birthmark.
Persistent indigestion, persistent hoarseness,
unexplained cough or difficulty in swallowing,
any change in normal bowel habits.
Pain is seldom a symptom of early cancer,
so don't forget these danger signals. Any
sore that does not heal, particularly about
the tongue, mouth, or lips.
A painless lump or thickening, especially in
the breasts, lips, or tongue. Irregular bleeding
or discharge from any natural body opening.
Progressive change in the color or the size
of a wart, mole or birthmark. Persistent indigestion,
persistent hoarseness, unexplained cough or
difficulty in swallowing. Any change in the
normal bowel habits.
At the first symptom, go to your doctor. If
necessary he will send you to a hospital for
a more complete examination than he can give
in his office.
Here at the hospital a highly trained team
will serve you. This team includes a physician
who has special knowledge of the microscopic
appearance of cancer tissue.
This pathologist will be able to tell your
doctor whether the growth you have is actually
cancer. If it is, early treatment can save
your life for yourself and loved ones.
[ Music ]
You must save yourself.  Remember the danger
signals. Go to your doctor at the first symptom.
Cancer must be stopped before it gets away.
[ Music ]
[The End]